for mains if there's a choice of three
smoked lamb shank with couscous and
spicy sausages fish wrapped in vine
leaves with white beans and that North
African staple chicken tagine with a
dish of course a very traditional I love
the way you taste every Thai team is
going out he may be doing every day but
you're still tasting it every time the
kitchen is focused while front of house
look busy but don't seem coordinated
patience in disguise there are lots of
waiters but it doesn't seem like the
managers of controlling service and some
of my diners have slipped through the
net
saber-6 coming about three minutes three
minutes just slowing down so we not get
everything kind of weird center it's
finding that balance one table complain
it's too far off on table complain who's
too slow just trying to find that
balance - who hasn't had their main
courses you know when you get thirty
customers at once you want to save it
like a party he's study hard to pace
yourself coming the narcos short-staffed
they seem to have a manager four
teaspoons and manage for the bread
manager for the lid the couscous so
service should be impeccable today so
they should get that balance ride you
can't serve a table two courses with one
table nothing
that's bad management and far too many
chiefs in dining room and not enough in
use in fact there's more managers in
this dining room there are grains of
[ __ ] Christmas
we definitely come again we said that as
soon as the main course a melting sir
it's a lovely feeling here we've been
made to feel very comfortable if you
take quite well it's coming to receive
my food and then bike waiting that
wasn't necessarily what we thought was
nice lunch is over but I'm disappointed
that service was inconsistent for some
of my diners timing was all over the
shop and that was down to the pursuit
inducing for managers far too many
managers and a real lack of
communication with the kitchen and thank
God David was on fire because we have
too many managers on the floor that
couldn't spot whooping stop what okay
big test that one you're used to big
numbers so 30 diners should have been a
walk in the park
how did it go for you very well I really
enjoy nice was a great bus
great atmosphere yeah great atmosphere
my biggest concern today was the fact
that there was one table next to the big
table that had their starters the main
courses and the six top had nothing to
eat when somebody hasn't got food in
front of them and they're eyeing up the
table next door to them they get jealous
we had two complaints capacity for the
pigeon if anything maybe not so small in
terms of dice so they can identify what
they've got on the fork is a piece of
pigeon he didn't say enough desserts I
thought that was the best creme brulee
I've ever tasted in a decade share the
starter but make sure you save room for
that dessert that's how good they are
well then
it's nice that feedback and if it's
negative or not good thing but you keep
showing your toes dancing crazy when a
great feeling and great passion and we
we're gonna win it we're here to win